- [Voiceover] What I want to do with
this video is come up with
the formula for the arc
length of a curve that's
defined in polar coordinates.
So, if this curve right over here is r
is equal to F of theta, how do we figure
out the length of this curve between two
thetas, say between theta is equal to,
well let's say, in this case, it looks
like between theta zero radius and say, pi
over two radius, but between
any two bounds for r theta.
So the way we're going to do this, an if
at any point you get excited or
inspired, you definitely should pause
the video and see if you can run with the
formula for arc length when you're
dealing with something in polar form.
But the way that we're going to tackle
it is the exact same way that we tackled
arc length when we were dealing with
standard rectangular coordinates.
So, let's take a little, small section of
the arc length, let's take a little small
section, I'm going to blow it up.
So, let's call this right over here,
this is our infinitesitely, this is our
infinitely smaller, infinitesimal sized,
our piece of our arc length,
I'm going to call it DS.
And obviously, this is
a lot bigger than maybe
you would imagine when you think of
infinitesimal, but then if you integrate
together all of the DSes, if you
integrate together all of the DSes, then
you're going to have, you're going to have
the length of the actual
curve that you care about.
So we can say that the length is going
to be all of the DSes integrated, all of
the infinitely, the infinite sum of all
these infinitely small, all of
these infinitely small DSes.
Now, to actually put this in terms we
can relate to in terms of Rs and thetas,
I'm first going to relate this to Xs and
Ys and then relate the Rs and thetas to
Xs and Ys, which we have seen before when
we have converted between polar
form and rectangular form.
So we know that this DS is going to be
equal to our infinitely
small change in X squared.
So if this is our,
going from this point to
that point, that's our
change in our arc length.
But this distance, right over here would
be our change in our X, I'll write that
as DX and I'm writing everything as
differentials, which is a little bit
mathematically, I guess we could say,
hand-wavy or loosey
goosey, but it gives you
a good conceptual understanding
of where this comes from.
You could, if we were a little bit more
precise, we could take DX, we could do
delta Xs and then eventually take limits
and all the rest, but I'll just go with
this because it makes a little bit, at
least for my brain, more conceptual sense.
So that's, that's our change in X when we
go from that point to that point.
Then this is our change in Y when we go
from this point to this point, DY.
And we've seen this before when we got
our justification for the arc length
formula rectangular coordinates, we
could say that DS is going to be equal
to the square root of DX squared, DX
squared, plus DY squared and this just
comes straight out of
the Pythagorean Theorum.
Plus DY squared, and then if we can
integrate these, then we're
kind of in the same place.
But how do we get these
in terms of Rs and thetas?
Well, to do that, we just have to remind
ourselves what X is in terms of r and
theta, what Y is in terms of r and theta.
So X, we know, is going to be equal to r
cosine of theta and we first saw this when
we just first were going back and forth
between polar and rectangular coordinates.
And Y is going to be r sine of theta.
And now we can use this to say what
DX and what DY are going to be.
DX is then going to be equal to, and we
have to remember that r is going to be a
function of theta, so actually, let me
write it this way, let me just rewrite it.
So X, we could also
write it as, F of theta
times cosine theta and Y is equal to
F of theta times sine of theta.
So now, what's a DX? DX is going to be,
this is just, we're just going
to apply the product rule here.
It's going to be F prime of theta,
derivative of the first expression times
the second one, times cosine to theta plus
the derivative of the second one.
Well, the derivative of cosine of theta is
negative sine of theta, so
we'll say minus sine theta.
Minus sine theta times the first
expressions, so F of theta, that was just
the product rule, that's our DX.
And then, of course, D theta, D theta.
Another way you could have said if you
treated these differentials like
numbers, you could divide both sides by
D theta, you would have the derivative of
X with respect to theta is this business
right over here, so those
are equivalent statements.
And also do the same thing for DY.
So DY, same again, by the product rule
is going to be F prime, F prime of theta
times sine of theta plus F of theta times
the derivative of sine of
theta, which is cosine of theta.
Cosine of theta, and now if we want to
figure out what DS is,
we're going to have to
take the sum of DX squared and
DY squared, so let's do that.
So, DX, DX squared is going to be equal
to, we just need to square all of this
business, so I'm just going to square
this and then multiply that times D theta
squared, so that's going to be equal to,
this is going to be F prime of theta
squared, cosine squared theta, minus 2
times the product of
these, minus 2 times F
prime of theta, F of theta, cosine theta,
sine theta, and then this one squared, so
negative times negative is a positive, so
plus F of theta squared, sine
squared, sine squared theta.
So that's DX squared, and then, of
course, we have the D theta, well not done
yet, then we have the D theta squared and
now let's figure out what DY squared is.
So, DY squared is going to be equal to...
Well, this term, squared, oh I have to
forget, this DY is going to have a D theta
at the end, don't want to forget that.
And so over here, this is going to be F
prime of theta squared, sine squared,
sine squared theta, and then two times
the products of these, so plus two times
F prime of, let me, F prime of theta, F of
theta, it's a little bit hairy, but we'll
see in a few it's going
to clean up nicely.
F of theta, cosine sine, cosine theta,
sine theta and then we just want to square
this plus F of theta
squared cosine, cosine
squared theta, and then D theta squared.
D theta squared, now let's
add these two together.
So let's add them together,
and what are we going to get?
So, if we add DX squared and DY squared,
we're going to get, so DX squared plus DY
squared plus DY squared is equal to.
So over here we have cosine squared
theta times F prime of theta squared and
then sine squared there times
F prime of theta squared.
So we can factor out an F prime of theta
squared, so it's going to be equal to,
so if we factor these characters out,
it's going to be F prime of theta squared
times, times cosine squared theta, cosine
squared theta plus sine squared theta.
Plus sine squared theta and we see that
that's going to simplify nicely, that this
is just going to be equal to one,
that's just one basic trig identity.
And then, these middle two terms
actually cancel out, this is negative of
this, so these two
cancel out and then over
here, we can factor out
an F of theta squared.
So, we could factor out an F of theta
squared, so it becomes plus F of theta
squared times sine squared theta, sine
squared theta plus cosine squared
theta, plus cosine squared theta.
Well, that simplifies nicely.
This is just going to be equal to one.
And then, we have these and then this D, D
theta squared is multiplied
times everything.
So, so everything right over here is going
to be, so times D theta, D theta squared.
You can almost view these as the
coefficients on D theta squared and
we added those two coefficients.
So, this is going to clean up nicely now,
so this simplifies as DX squared plus DY
squared plus DY squared is equal to, is
equal to F prime of
theta squared plus F of
theta plus F of theta squared.
And then all of that
times, I'm going to do
this in a new color, actually.
All of that times D theta squared.
Actually, that, I've
already used that color.
I'll use the magenta.
All of that times D theta
squared, D theta squared.
Now we know that DS is going to be the
square root of this, so let's write that,
so DS is equal to the square root of this,
which is equal to the square root of this.
Which is going to be equal to, well we
can factor out a, the square root of D
theta squared is just going to be D
theta, so we can just take that out.
And we are left with, we are left with F
prime of theta squared. F prime of theta
squared plus F of theta squared,
plus F of theta squared.
And now we take a D theta out of the
radical, if you put it
in as D theta squared,
you take it out, it's going
to be D theta, D theta.
So this is interesting, so if we wanted
to integrate them, so if you wanted to
integrate this, if you want to integrate
this, if you want to integrate this, you
just want to integrate
this right over here.
And you would integrate it from your
starting theta, maybe we could call that
alpha, to your ending theta, beta.
And just like that, we have given
ourselves a reasonable justification, or
hopefully a conceptual understanding, for
the formula for arc length when we're
dealing with something in polar form.
If you have r is equal to F of theta,
you find what F prime of theta is, or
you could think of it as the derivative
of r with respect to theta, square that,
add that to F of theta squared, take the
square root and then integrate with
respect to theta from alpha to beta.
And so this right over
here, our arc length,
is going to be equal to
this right over here.
And the next few videos, we
will actually apply this.